[Music]
Samuel leaves here and welcome to
winners on a Wednesday today's Wednesday
and we have some absolute winners on the
show
welcome to Cheryl and Leah how you guys
doing good awesome you guys have been
well living with me all day training you
guys have got such an incredible story
why don't you just tell us briefly what
you've achieved in the last six weeks
and then we'll go through the whole
story in detail so what's going on right
now so at the minute we've got seven
went to essay deals and we've also got a
bicycle at a cello so we've made feels
yes eight deals in how many weeks we
love count three six
that's like more than one deal a week
yeah I think and these aren't just deals
in the pipeline these you've got a bite
chill out you've got seven read two
essays some of them you've got actually
got the keys for yeah yeah going through
it you've got guests in right now as we
speak
yeah what kind of profit are you
generating from these deals well I mean
in terms of on the air phase it should
average about two thousand to two and a
half thousand per so altogether we're
talking like what about fourteen
fourteen thousand pounds that is
ridiculous like you're not the only ones
obviously we've had other people doing
this on the Academy but the thing that
is so shocking about you two
I mean I knew you were gonna do well
when we first met on the Power Team
mother and daughter
but six weeks no weeks 14 grand alibi'd
to let poverty like that is incredible
what's your background
what do you do and so I'm an accountant
by profession side right so when you say
14,000 pounds we know you're not making
up because you're an accountant yeah
yeah and these are conservative numbers
as well thank you guys yeah so you're an
accountant by trade how about you Leah
so I used to work as a marketing
assistant I recently graduated as well
and then I'm just full time in property
now where yeah just quit
high-five when when did you quit your
job how I'm good like a month ago I
think it was two weeks after joining the
Academy yeah and I got a message from
Rex who's your coach on the Academy and
Rex said did you know that Lia and
Cheryl have got any told me the deals
and stuff
and I remember speaking to by telephone
and you would and then I said why don't
you come along to one of our things we
can celebrate get some drinks you came
down Lia helped quit one of the crash
courses and you when you got those like
housework and you said what did you say
you were like I've quit I quit
like talk to me about my house happened
then I mean six weeks is just incredible
I know it's been a lot of hard work you
guys have been living and breathing it
yeah I mean he came really quickly after
the crash course so we had obviously had
the crash cause yeah they came on our
coaching day here actually and then
literally the day after and I was gone
about the day after we've always done
stuff so the day after we got in touch
with a business contact that we know in
Birmingham asked him whether he still
had this property that was available
which he did and he basically sort of
said yeah you know you can have it so
that's how our first one came about and
then the second one yeah we just kind of
we came on PPU yeah we came on the PPE
heard the training literally the same
evening we've kind of went back rather
than going straight home we went to a
restaurant went to Cheetos yeah really
glamorous and literally just sat there
indeed what we were told to do on the
course loved it and off the back of that
we then got the deal through through the
estate agent and have you done any
previous property training programs and
you do nothing no experience and in this
no no that is that is incredibly laughs
no man I mean leah has been watching
your videos so while those this year
nagging me for ages well we've got go on
these craftsmen what what what held you
back what made you not come along soon
if you'd have known what would have
happened would you have been booking on
my wife oh yeah I think we did booked on
quite quickly to be fair when we started
what is finding the time yeah and I was
just finishing the Uni and working full
time
yeah at same time so I've seen as I was
doing I was like yeah and you've got
guests I remember when you
you know I remember their message you
mean sign oh my god you've got guests
going in and yeah what did you think
when you actually started making seeing
the money how did it feel just the ring
it's still a bit surreal now explain it
but yeah it is very strange having
guests and we had our first booking
within within literally a few hours I
can't believe it we would just drive in
and then it was like we've got a book in
and I was like where's that coming from
it was literally in like 2 days time and
it was like wait this is like real now
yeah pretty much constantly being booked
out and you've been doing this via
finding apartments in city centres been
working in Birmingham and you've been
finding apartments and you've been
basically giving the landlord a
guaranteed when yeah and then you've
obviously did it properly you've got the
correct contracts you've got the correct
permission yeah yeah it's everything you
did you did it completely properly yeah
and making crazy money
what what are your future plans then
Cheryl I mean making kind of that sort
of money I mean obviously yeah I mean
one of my key reasons for going easy
this time I having more time with family
is Lear's the one that keeps gonna do
all the training programs because you've
already quit your job now yes just cause
she's at every deal finding stomach
cancer in fact someone even I don't know
if you knew this is there but when Lea
came to the crash course that's
obviously I think there was was there
like nine people at the crash course
that will find out 2012 there was a big
number of people at the crash course who
were all in your boat yeah financially
free someone making just two grand a
month somewhere making 20 grand a month
yeah and and I said hey if you're
financially free come on to the stage
and Leah came up and a bunch people come
up and Leah got accused of being a plant
she's just said she's just an apple set
it all up and she's getting paid to be
there to try to find her
but lie but honestly did you know that
ya know I do have a few people and
they're like why are you here like they
pay you to say this and I'm like no I'm
here because I literally I love it and
it's changing it's like yeah I take when
we went to the crash course yeah I
challenge anybody to come to this crash
course and free not to be a game changer
literally be alive because for us I
could just tell when we went on those
two days that we were gonna take it and
just go for it and you have I mean
obviously I can only show people what I
did yeah and give people tools yeah and
then it's that you know it's down to
people to that implement it yeah and you
know it's not easy it's it's it's hard
it's not easy but it is possible yeah
and the fact that you've done in such a
short amount of time it's very easy
people just think oh you know go on a
training course and it's just like a
magic wand
no the only training course learn the
skills practice implement and then go
put it to work I'm sorry first like
having been to the Academy I don't think
we'd have had the success that we've had
yeah had we not signed it the Academy
yeah gone on the extra trainees death
but and it is a lot of hard work you
know service accommodation is is not an
easy road to go through not really hard
work but we've really enjoyed it yeah we
still had a smile on our faces yeah what
do you think about a like that you do
service accommodation but you're also
doing buy-to-let yeah
because service what do you think about
the longevity I mean right now there's
so many people on who are coming on the
crash course or joining the Academy I do
renting properties then renting them out
of serviced accommodation doing it
probably make it absolute killing do you
think that will be possible long term or
do you think that right now is just the
golden moment I think I'm sure some
regulations gonna come in or something
you know I can imagine in five years or
ten years time people saying those were
their day yes yeah people will be
commenting on this video
2025 say Oh
it was easy now well if you're watching
this video do something now in 2018-19
don't wait till 2020 25 those you know
those people will irritate me yeah yeah
because you could do that you could say
oh 2008 I started I was buying
properties below market value
refinancing them the same day putting
that all my money yeah those were the
days
well guess what the days are also now
yeah absolutely but at the same time you
also want to have longevity and the
money that you're making 14 grand a
month I'm sure that will go up yeah you
might get it to 30 grand a month or
whatever yeah but then the money that
you're making like 14 grand a month
that's enough to put down a deposit on a
house yeah exactly
so so I love the fact that you're
investing the profits yeah I think
that's super smart yeah it's kind of I
guess we look at the FRS of like the
cash flow element of the business about
we'll just yeah you know keep turning
out keep bringing cash in so that we can
can then reinvest it in you know it's by
Colette's or big development yeah well
well and that's what you want to do
right yeah when we had our one-to-one
like what was that like six weeks ago
yeah when you officially started the
Academy during the crash course already
and we set goals together yes what were
the goals that we set you remember it
was one rent to assailant from what
enters lick one deal through you okay
did I leave anything but you like
killing the other side yeah just for the
viewers what what is what is and you can
either do that as an academy you can do
that through our company Alastair
whatever or you can find your own
investor so continuous we started
looking but where was so time
constrained anyway because timely it was
like working for slave driver so she was
working like night or 6:00
yeah so we were really time poor we
thought actually we probably just need
to prioritize on if we're looking at
stuff make sure that it's a deal that we
could go for all week sell it yeah and
so then we just ended up falling into
deals that we just thought look they're
just too good to pass on yeah yeah
- good tell us about the corner money
did you have a massive pot to start with
did you have a lot of money in the bank
not matheus
not massive so we're looking at a pot of
about 80 grand
don't come up from like refinancing and
yeah but that's kind of coming through
property there and then yeah so you've
pulled money out of your own house so so
and again sometimes people I haven't got
any money to invest for how much yeah
not how much mood you have in the bank
but you need to look at how much and
when did you have access to exactly so
and we did this on the one-to-one yeah
you know have you got people have you
got friends and family they've got money
yeah can you get a mortgage can you get
a loan have you equity in your house
what and we worked out that you had
about 80 K yeah and you chose to buy a
buy to let with that yeah what is the
bottle at the bottle it is quite simple
so that's still going through but you
know progressed that far on so we've
literally bought that's like 74 yep it
down no it's a multi-layer so four rooms
multi let probably so so you'll probably
rent that out for about how much about
400 per room 400 put that's like a lot
for 74 grand now yeah we're big
refurbish and you know tell me more than
anyone yeah because you live in town but
and now you're a Birmingham girl perfect
so you bought it a 74 grand and I think
it's a 74 I think it'll take 25 to do up
yeah the advantage was when I went to
the viewing the being was actually the
estate agent was doing the viewing
actually sent that builder to do the
viewings you could say you know what you
need space this space it's gonna cost
that so it was really easy to just make
a decision straight away yeah when you
do you're gonna refinance it love it
love it
you've really implemented everything
haven't you yeah absolutely everything
and also you've been finding people on
the Academy that are successful you've
been picking their brain grabbing it
chop it into less yeah yeah yeah and I
think that's one of the great things
about the Academy that there's people
doing all different types of property
strategies you can just go who's
successful yeah it's just for this and
then and then pick their brain week
fantastic yeah so so that will that end
up being like I want a no money down
little money now very little money dad
I'm gonna check in you're leaving I
think we only have left in about 7 or 8
K at the most and then you'll be making
a profit on that of how much a month
profit should be about a thousand if you
can if you can pull that off that will
be like another dream deal people could
easily say about you
everything you touch it seems to be turn
into gold but we know that we know that
in order to get a yes in order to get a
deal you need to get a lot of rejection
first tell us about some of the
rejection and some of the knows you've
had yeah I guess with the essay is it
was when we recall in the estate agents
and literally everyone said no apart
from one but then because we're now in
with that one age and that sort of
helped us to get the sort of the deals
that come hardest yeah I say this on the
cross course your hardest do is always
your I mean I loved that book a
recommendation that we got from Trevor
yeah go for now did you ever feel like
giving up in the early days oh I'd say
early days this was like six weeks ago
but you know I mean I don't think you've
got a lot of knows but you know from the
training that you'd had that that was
normal right yeah yeah okay and also
like this whole setting up of the
service accommodation organizing the
cleaners and the this and the back get
in that setup is a nightmare in such a
short space of time I know you've had
obviously assistance and help us but how
have you managed to do all that without
having a heart attack with the amount of
time that's been involved because you've
got a full time busy job I know you've
quit Leah but that is a lot of setup I
just think we just like dedicate all at
home to it committed yeah all we talk
about now family friends yeah literally
everybody everybody that's come to it
when we were setting up they knew they
were gonna have to so friends of ours
you know they said right they're gonna
come down and have a look at it should
we bring the drill was like yeah bring
the drill you know and they put in me
and the ring calm forest and the key
safe and yeah
but it's just chipped in basically so
good so good
I think it's Grant Cardone who says you
know the average or obsessed you don't
have to be obsessed forever I mean if
you wanted to now you could just sit
back let the money come in yeah you know
but that that's incredible what would
you say your biggest key to success is
100% is taking action straightaway as
soon as if you don't take action what
about you anything I think been your
possession you know just being willing
to work so you know past midnight
coming in the next day to shoot the
apartment you've literally got to be
willing to do whatever it takes so true
that's why I get I don't know if you saw
my rant but I did did you see at the
office room yeah my office man did you
see that you were probably working you
too busy being in your business
i I was just talking about people that
say oh the crash course is three hours
away so I'll wait for one to come in my
hometown and how it's like listen if
you're not gonna even overcome the first
the first hurdle yeah of getting trained
you're never gonna be successful anyways
yeah so you guys are just you measure
just continue watching EastEnders yeah
you know I mean like it does take a
whatever it takes
mentality in order to get a extremely
good successful result I mean it just
does so especially if you're starting
from I know you started that you had a
bit of money but if you're wanting to
start from nothing or a little and get
something extreme like there's some
people in the Academy or who come to the
crash course they've got you know a
hundred grand yeah and they just want to
passively invest their it for them it
might not be hard yeah but to start and
get these rental rate deals yeah kind of
hustle and bustle and to get the ticket
like eight deals in six weeks is hustle
yeah you know and you're 80 grand how
much of that have you spent because
boozing actually because people watch
this video story grab yo how much you
spent
we have spent money yeah so in terms of
getting off the first essay off the
ground your rents up front and all of
your letting agent fees you know it was
quite a price we've probably spent at
that eight grand
yeah sure but then but then it should be
making 14 grand a month
yeah I mean yeah you're gonna still the
return was like yeah lately we had to do
the number two or three times we're like
this let me tell you an investment it's
like two hundred and seventeen percent
it's like crazy
yeah absolutely crazy but the thing is
that people would always make excuses
you know yeah ooh you some losers will
say you were plant some losers will say
oh you started with money and I haven't
some losers will say you live in a
better City than made all these excuses
what would you advise me to them
I mean we we know for sure that we could
have done this with less money down so
now that we've gone into we've spoken to
more people like Lesniak
because you can rent the furniture yeah
we haven't done any of that
yeah so but eight grams is with us
buying everything out right yeah because
we just didn't have time to mess around
around it so actually we could have
probably been it for cheap because
that's the thing and you've also you've
implemented there's there's a balance
lot you guys are the biggest
implementers I know which is why you're
successful but but you've also educated
yourself but I think there's a healthy
balance between educate implement
educate implement yeah because there's
nothing more scary than a motivated
idiot so someone's running ahead yeah
with no knowledge
now you're going to struggle to have
that happen to you on the academy yeah
but but what you're doing is you're
running ahead but then the knowledge is
kind of captured up which is probably
the best way to do it yeah you don't
want to be a stuffed turkey with all the
knowledge of no limitation but you don't
want to be a massive implementer with no
knowledge yeah so you're kind of
learning as you go in yeah I mean I
probably I think more slightly more
risk-averse than earlier I think that's
my accountants background so when it
came to the the latest deal with the
properties I sort of said she was just
take one listen we just take Warner fees
but they are perfect you know perfect
location perfect so that's about these
five then Leah you're going to be living
in like one yeah so I'm gonna live in
one so it's a block of six so you
haven't even included that in the
figures no oh yeah and I'm also gonna be
able to live rent-free
shucks about a boob alright so you're
gonna be living in one
yeah I'm still got eight deals on top of
that you got you got nine deals yeah I
guess yeah yeah cool so it's a nine
deals in six weeks even better so you're
gonna live anymore on the others I mean
what's the what's the deal how did you
negotiate that so it was through the age
and that we spoke to you before and we
sort of said you have any more sort of
similar setup to what we like she was
like oh yeah I've got this sort of block
of apartments okay we'll have a look and
then I went in feud one and then I was
like hanging out quite like them and
then you went in for you yeah then and
then we just ended up with the one and
we were like okay the location because
obviously location is key and the thing
that I guess I had forgotten is that
there's the hospital like really nearby
new layer that reminded me and said
there's a hospital like you were
wondering if they were gonna work
proceed with caution you know we do sort
of analyze it so when we decided that
the location could work I then sort of
said okay well maybe we'll take two yeah
still being quite cautious and then when
I contacted the estate agent and
realized that actually somebody was hot
on our heels
you know because they'd been looking at
the same properties that we had that one
and another post possible ready to rent
lose you lose right and these kind of
properties you know they don't mess
about mess around with us on the market
or was it off market only one of them
was on the market so the key is then to
get in with the state agents yeah how do
you get in with the state agents I mean
I think you get you got a you gotta get
in that you gotta build a relationship
yeah you know and I hear that a lot on
the courses here and it's very true yeah
you really have got to build a
relationship build that credibility and
then obviously get in you know be really
responsible in terms of how you treat
the property all of those sort of things
as soon as they see it they fell first
it was the hardest yeah those deals the
hardest when you get one it's almost
like a tap yeah absolutely
she actually said to us she said oh this
is a company similar to you that wants
to do the same thing that you're doing
but I've already know you guys I've got
the relationship
with you etcetera so you know fantastic
love that so what's next time for you
guys who knows yeah and and we've
already started thinking very much about
our strategy for the essays yeah so we
don't want to just be a run-of-the-mill
essay you know we're already kind of
like you know going for extra training
and stuff like that so we've been
speaking to like a few local hotels we
really want to kind of up the standard
of all know that you want to be the best
raise the bar in terms of how we manage
and systemize which obviously I've
learnt from you and Russell yeah about
systemising so key so we're just know
we're kind of focusing very much on that
because once we've done that then we
just want to grow yes grow do say it's
not probably be Lea's baby to be fair
yeah what what's your experience of the
Academy being so far then amazing yeah
it's just really unlocked you know if
you go on the crash course which is free
which is great really for how much
training you get and first the Academy
was almost been the catalyst that just
helped her yeah you know some kind of
radio Lee [ __ ] yeah I think would have
struggled if we just in the crash cause
we have to have the Academy to build
well wanting to achieve what you've
achieved yeah I mean it's a very
ambitious goal right yeah some people go
on the crash course and then just go
thank you very much and do it and then
they go on they implement in their own
way yeah but for what
with no background in property at all
and wanting to really go forward with
your course we'd started like
shortlisting some things annika but we
still weren't sure and so we haven't
actually gotten viewed anything and also
the crash course there's hundreds of
people that yeah where I was on the
academy you know it's very intimate
yeah it's a whole different total second
day once we had that goal we were like
right we're all that we know what we do
and when the coaching calls know when I
set you your goals what we did together
yeah did you did you think it was gonna
be did you think like oh my gosh if I
could just do that it'll be amazing it
was a little bit daunting
yeah I know it's real I know I don't
even think I was really sure how rents
rent worth yeah yes I know just gotta go
and do it and if you'd have known
six weeks ago what you'd have achieved I
mean what would you not face oh cool
yeah yeah well that's fantastic Leah
what would you say to someone who was
younger at you because you how old are
you 21 21 21 what would you say to
someone watching this who's 21 just went
starts out really inspired and doesn't
know what to do next what would you say
I say hundred percent get down to the
crash course yeah and join the Academy
and just fully get committed to it and
you're every single crash course now
pretty much there so you'll be there you
love that so much guys thank you for
come on the show and well it's what I do
your success is my oxygen and you know
how I roll you make a move I make 10
moves so thanks so much and looking
forward to continuing kicking ass in the
next few minutes why thank you thank you
so much for watching the video that is
the reason why I'm doing this
your success is my oxygen every single
week we've got people becoming
financially free if you'd like to see
more success students you can do that
right here but what I'd really suggest
is why don't you come and join us at the
property investors crash course come on
on my guest completely free and I'll
personally be there for two days to help
you get started you can see what happens
right here what you'll notice is all of
these stories they all start at the
crash course so come along my guests
can't wait to see you there peace out